we're going to begin with urgent
warnings from America's top medical
experts that the US could hit 100,000
daily cases of the corona virus without
action nearly 45,000 cases were reported
just yesterday that's according to Johns
Hopkins and that is the second highest
total since the pandemic started about
45 percent of those cases came from just
three states they are Florida Texas and
right here in California each reported
more than six thousand cases yesterday
top health officials told lawmakers
yesterday they're very concerned the
u.s. is heading the wrong way we are now
having 40 plus thousand new cases a day
I would not be surprised if we go up to
a hundred thousand a day if this does
not turn around it is critical that we
all take the personal responsibility to
slow the transmission of COBIT 19 and
embrace the universal use of face
coverings also on Capitol Hill the
Senate passed an extension of the
paycheck protection program hours before
it was set to expire if the House
approves small businesses will have
until August 8 to apply for federal help
doctor ashish is the director of the
Harvard Global Health Institute and he
testified before the Senate on the
pandemic response just yesterday joins
us now dr. Shah good morning dr. Fauci
we heard say we could have a hundred
thousand new cases per day in the
not-too-distant future how do we avoid
that and perhaps the better question is
how do we get people to actually follow
the guidelines that we know can work yes
sir good morning and thank you for
having me on we can't avoid it we don't
want a hundred thousand cases a day and
we can avoid it we know what works we
got to get everybody to where mass we've
got to really think about indoor
gatherings and whether we can afford
them I think largely we can't no bars no
nightclubs no gems and then we've got to
keep going on testing and tracing if we
can do those things we can get there but
to your question of how do we get people
to comply that's leadership that's
leaders coming out with a consistent
message every day about the importance
of exactly those things you mentioned
yesterday in your testimony on Capitol
Hill that you'd like to see a stronger
response short of that is there a way
that state-by-state there can be enough
of a response to actually slow this
thing yeah so you know we have not had
much in the way of a coordinated federal
response and so we have seen sort of 50
responses to the pandemic and some of
them have been very strong I think some
governors have done a fabulous job and
I'd like to see more governors take this
on but at the end of the day it's gonna
be hard to fight the biggest pandemic in
a century if the federal government is
absent so I do think states can do a lot
but a lot be really helpful if the
federal government helped yeah the
trajectory here seems pretty clear there
are certain segments of the population
that no matter how many times someone
like yourself says wear a mask wash your
hands stay distant it's not gonna to
sink in so can we at least say that the
hospitals and that the medical community
is more prepared now than perhaps they
were in April or May yeah I do think
we're more prepared we've gotten better
at taking care of this disease we have
more protective equipment but by no
means is it sort of foolproof and I'm
worried that hospitals are starting to
run out of beds we are starting to run
out of protective equipment so I still
think there's some serious challenges
ahead
we heard the director of the CDC
mentioned that he'd like to see
universal face coverings but face
coverings are not all created equal and
I want to show people some quick video
here the first image that they're going
to see is just a cough no face cover
covering at all you can see the the
germs spreading out almost 12 feet next
up is a bandana face covering you can
see what comes out of your mouth
contained a little bit more third is a
surgical covering surgical grade face
mask and then finally after we see that
one you can see better containment there
and in pole position very interestingly
a stitched covering which seemed to be
working best of all that is just a
something you're it would be made on a
sewing machine at home when you see
those differences there in terms of how
germs are contained what does that tell
you about what we should be wearing
clearly they're not all created equal
yes sir they're not all created equal
and obviously I first of all I think all
of the evidence not just to study but
others suggest that something is better
than nothing so any face covering is
better
than doing nothing at all but yeah
absolutely those surgical masks are
better the sis clothing cloth masks are
better if people can do those and those
are largely accessible now so people can
do those that would certainly be a big
improvement over bandanas and all of it
is better than nothing at all yeah you
mentioned we are 50 states we've had 50
different responses Europe is also a
collection of countries they've had
different responses but when you look at
the continent there they've been able to
bend the curve in ways we haven't what
lessons can we learn from Europe yeah so
there's one lesson I think then one
lesson only in some ways at the end of
the day which is that we got to take
this virus seriously you know Germany
took a different approach than Italy
which took a different approach than
Denmark so countries can take different
approaches and get there but all of them
took it seriously all of them did social
distancing and really aggressive testing
and that to me are key features that all
of us have to do in the United States
yeah last question here I think a lot of
people are waiting on the vaccine that
might return us to normalcy how hopeful
are you the end of the year is still a
good time table
I think end of the year is gonna be
extremely difficult look we may have a
vaccine that we've identified by the end
of the year but we don't just need to
have a vaccine we need to feel
comfortable that it's safe that it's
effective even if we have it identified
producing hundreds of millions of doses
which I know we're getting going on now
but having it ready for people I think
it'll be more like spring of next year
if everything goes well all right dr.
Shi sha thank you very much